you can build a habit with the quran by
seven day free trial bonuses no credit
card details required at all and you
decide for yourself is it overrated or
is it underrated go to the link in the
description box below on sisters android
and ios the link is there download it
and see what time it is
before the video starts guys let me just
give you guys clarification inshallah
because um the discussion starts
abruptly uh so here in surah masad
here's the miracle of the quran allah
says with the name of allah almost for
the very most world bismillah
perish the two hands of abu lahab and
perish he neither his wealth benefit him
nor what he earned he will soon enter a
fire full of flames and his wife as well
the wicked carry of firewood around
around her neck there is a cut of iron
like a well-twisted rope so the claim is
this when abu lahab the prophet's uncle
heard this it is clearly telling him
that he is going to enter the fire as a
disbeliever
but
the question is he could have easily
disprove islam how watch this video and
now it will make sense and very
interestingly this this young man that i
was talking to was a sincere man who
took this on board and went home with
some quran and other material and we
asked allah to guide him to islam enjoy
the video yeah
what is one thing that you have to do to
disprove my book
to become a
disbeliever a believer okay because if
my claim is that you my god is telling
me that you're going to die as a
disbeliever all you have to say is oh is
it okay i accept islam yeah yeah i
believe and then my book i'm like your
book is false yeah but they said i'm
gonna die as this believer guess what it
is disbeliever and he heard this all he
had to do was this
i believe in i believe in the one god
your religion is false and he died of
this believer
that is mad but all you have to do is
say
we have to say
islam is supposed but he dies as a
disbeliever he that prophecy that came
true and he ordered his own ears
if you have any questions